well first of all congratulations I
think one of the the things about
tonight one of the best things is
everybody you know you won you're good
if you can kind of relax right you need
to sit there and wonder I hope they call
my name or that that anxiety is off that
face of What's it gonna look like if I
do hear my name if I don't hear my name
I'm new to this whole routine so um I'm
gonna have to practice that one before
we find ourselves lucky enough to be in
that seat at that time you know one of
the things I think is really great and I
know we talked to you on the red carpet
one of the things I thought that you
said that was so great was you know what
you are paying attention to all of this
you are like hearing the noise and and
and finding yourself really kind of
being present through award season and
feeling the butterflies I love that
Brendan I kind of got it together
between then and now
um but I have to say I was just telling
Hong backstage I became really quite
emotional before I walked on for the
kind remarks that she made in her
introduction well listen you you I mean
I know how much you love him I talked to
you during when we were talking about
the movie and you were telling me there
was that moment where you looked at him
and and something switched it was during
a read or a rehearsal or something
something happened to this man and how
great has it been to see like when you
see that moment happen and now you see
everything that's coming behind it for
him
well I want Brendan to win all of the
Awards come on we can manifest as 20 20
minutes okay we gonna manifest what we
can manifest
I was very touched that Brendan wanted
me to present this award for him today
that it's the first one to kick off
award season and I hope I I did an okay
job
um
it was really such a joy thinking of
what to say about him there was just so
much you know we jokingly say it's this
Renaissance you know what I'm saying but
really it is I think people's
opportunity to give you your flowers for
what you said 32 years of coming to work
this year you're the valedictorian of
that class
you know what I'm saying I mean really
if you can can you wrap your head around
this or or are you just saying I'm gonna
float through it apart I still feel like
I'm just getting started to tell you the
truth I love it I I'm not done yet
we're young and ambitious still
it's gonna it's gonna be an interesting
Journey it's it's not over well one of
many and this is pretty she's she's art
right this is a creation of Dale Chihuly
I just found out who's also from Seattle
the glassblower glass maker
spectacularly creative
I'm gonna have to make some room for it
somewhere
um on a shelf I guess maybe take a few
shelf spaces out
like I said this is one of many so get
ready how many suits you got how many
tuxes you got you ready
um I I got one me and I'm ready to jump
into any of them at any time
foreign